[music]
>> The next translation
is Muhammad Asad.
Muhammad Asad, he originally was a
Originally means before he accepted
Islam,
he was a Jew.
His name was Leopold Weiss.
He was a very good writer, mashallah.
And he accepted Islam and he had skills
of writing. His English is
phenomenal.
And
mashallah, he translated the Quran.
Let me tell you that all the
translations available,
you'll be shocked to know many a time
the translator doesn't know Arabic as a
language also.
Or may know just Persian.
Even I don't know Arabic as a language.
People think I know, I don't know.
Little bit here and there, fine. I went
for a few weeks. I tried a lot,
mashallah. My son was better bit older
You know, they teach in our school.
Children from the age of three Arabic.
So, this translation by Leopold Weiss is
fantastic in terms of English. He has
not done word-to-word translation. He
has done paraphrasing. Means translation
one, two, three together. Because he
felt that translating and putting them
in one paragraph would be easier to
understand. So, verse number one, two,
three is together, then four to eight is
together, then seven and eight
paraphrasing. Paraphrasing means few
verses together. So, when you read
the translation, you may find sometimes
only one verse.
Sometimes it is
joint. And then he writes there
verse numbers mentioned,
but it's more of a paraphrasing.
So, in one paragraph is verse number
one, two, three. The next paragraph is
four, five. So, it is paraphrasing. You
come to know the verse number, but he
feels that like a paragraph if you read,
it's better.
It's a very good translation,
but
it has got drawbacks.
And some drawbacks are very major.
It is the best translation that I know
of, which goes to the linguistic You
know, there's something like linguistic
translation of the Quran.
Going to the root word.
And in the Arabic
tafasir, one of the best tafasir is
going to the linguistic and logic, it is
Zamakhshari.
We will not be dealing with Arabic
tafasir here, but Zamakhshari is a very
good
It is the best tafsir available on
logic, on mantiq, but
very dangerous
for a layman.
Very good. Something which is good can
be dangerous.
Very dangerous because it sometimes uses
logic and even
disagrees with the miracles.
And tries to prove the miracles
logically.
Very dangerous.
So, for a student of knowledge, it is
very good, but for a lay Muslim, I would
not recommend this.
But if a person wants to read a variety
of translation, understand, I refer it.
I do refer to it, but I'm careful
what to agree, what to disagree. So, if
you have that knowledge of Islam where
you can decipher between the
good and the bad and the authentic and
unauthentic, then you can refer to any
book in the world. Otherwise,
abstain from referring
to such books cuz you read something and
you like your logic says yes, so one of
the major faults is also he has tried to
logically talk about Miraj. You know
Miraj, the ascension? So, he'll give you
a scientific explanation which a normal
man will say what?
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam went
on Miraj. So, he's tried to prove it
it wasn't a physical ascension.
The verse of Surah Isra, chapter number
17, verse number one.
That Allah transported him from Masjid
al-Haram to Masjid al-Aqsa.
Anyway, I'm not
We haven't even done the Quran.
The time
is very short, 1 hour 50 minutes.
I should have expanded it.
So, this translation, but the logical
arguments and he has quoted many a times
Zamakhshari.
His main base
And Zamakhshari is a very important
tafsir.
It should be referred by students who
are doing tafsir of Quran. Should. But
for layman, no.
Those are major faults in Zamakhshari
which if you don't know, you can go
astray.
But if you know, it's a very good
reference tafsir.
Okay, that we'll come to later on. So,
Muhammad Asad
has
taken a lot and he goes to the root
word.
There's no harm in going to root word.
And even today,
I don't know the name,
but there are famous dais who go to
linguistic.
Linguistic words, oh this Quran means
this. And when you hear, you are
enthralled about it. All right, Quran so
the Quran meaning is this. There is no
harm, but whenever you take the help of
anything else when you're giving a
tafsir of the Quran, the major base of
the commentary or the translation should
it
sahih hadith.
When you're taking something else like
lugha
and you understand the Quran but what
does it mean Arabic wise? No problem.
But if that translation or if you go to
a dictionary language like the
dictionary we'll come to it later on.
Very good.
But if you take that meaning that this
word has three meanings and you pick up
one meaning which is matching your logic
but is contradicting the sahih hadith it
should be rejected.
So you go to know this has so many
meanings and you go. Okay, if you pick
up a meaning
which is different than the other
translators but doesn't contradict the
hadith no problem.
So when you start doing this tafsir
tafsir bin rai or tafsir we'll come to
that later on.
A translation using lugha good but you
should have strong knowledge of hadith.
If you use this
and you don't have a strong knowledge of
hadith and you start
doing tafsir of the verse of the Quran
which is right linguistically but not
correct according to sahih hadith it's a
major problem.
Then you start giving your commentary
then you start saying things which are
against the sahih hadith.
So
Muhammad Asad
same.
Very good.
Very beneficial.
Also dangerous.
May Allah grant him Jannah.
He's done
a great work.
But we as students of knowledge
should be careful and should know the
drawbacks.
The next translation
The Glorious Quran by Abdul Majid
Daryabadi. This
translation also some say tafsir
comes in four volumes.
This is the one I think they bought the
one volume correct? Yes. I mean I just
told Kalim to pick it up from the
library but I know that it comes in four
volumes. This is the concise
version.
This per se is very good as far as
comparative religion is concerned. So,
if you want to refer to a translation
which has got good references from the
Bible and the other scriptures of the
other religions, this Abdul Majid
Daryabadi has done a good job.
And Abdul Majid Daryabadi makes it very
clear at the beginning of his
translation.
He says very clearly that Quran is the
most untranslatable book in the world.
The most difficult book to translate
in the world is the Quran.
Not the best book in the world, but the
language of the Quran is so divine,
pure,
intelligible, and it is
but he has a very good job. The main
point is he has given
a lot of references from the works of
scriptures of other religions, but at
the same time you as a guy should check
up that this references given does it
contradict with the Hadith or not?
Most of the time when they give
references, it doesn't contradict the
Quran. But may contradict the sahih
Hadith. So, you as a student of
knowledge should check up, not blindly
pick up anything when you're using as a
hujja.
The next translation
is by Muhammad Marmaduke Pickthall.
The meaning of the Glorious Quran by
Muhammad Marmaduke Pickthall. Now, this
translation again is a very famous
translation amongst the old translations
at the time of the life of Ali and
Muhammad Marmaduke Pickthall.
It is a very good work again. The
English is good. But again, it's a pure
translation.
Doesn't have
any commentary.
Has very less footnotes. It's somewhat
similar to Say International, but Say
International is a later one, more
modern English. It is
for the present
modern English people. Muhammad
Marmaduke Pickthall again is a very
famous translation, and the translation
alhamdulillah is a good translation.
Now, mainly I prefer
if you refer to a translation which is
directly from
Arabic to English.
So, these were the few samples I've
given from Arabic to English directly.
There are many others.
I bring Sudan. In the library we have
I think more than
80 90 English translations of the Quran.
Only English in
languages we have
more than
50 60 languages. Each language multiple
copies.
This is the meaning of the Quran by
Maulana Abul Ala Maududi Rahimullah.
And Sayyid Abul Ala Maududi again
it is a translation which is separate
concise volume Mukhtasar.
This is only translation Understanding
the Quran done by Zafar Ishaq Ansari.
His translation again, let's see each
translation has its own specialty as I
mentioned.
Maulana Maududi, may Allah grant him
Jannah.
Rahimullah.
He was the first person
about 37 years back
who got the King Faisal Award.
When King Faisal Award first time when
it came,
the first person who got the King Faisal
Award was Sayyid Abul Ala Maududi.
May Allah grant him Jannah. He has done
great good works. But again, there are
many books written against him. We are
not here to discuss that right or wrong.
He's done great good works. May Allah
reward him for all the good work he has
done.
But every translator has his own point
Like if I speak, I look at the Dawah
angle.
Every Quranic verse has got different
angles.
That same Quranic verse may convince
10 different people. May convince a
scientist. May convince an ignorant
person. May convince a person who is
expert in literature.
But the translation of
Abul Ala Maududi is more focused
on Iqamat-ud-Din. He has that concept
that we should establish the Din and
which every Muslim does believe. No
doubt about it. But then he looks at
every verse in that way.
So, if you want to know about that is
concept, so that is a good talking about
a comment in the D. Establishing
the D.
of Allah.
Everyone believes that Allah D should be
established, but not every verse is only
talking about that. Emphasis is more on
that.
It's a good translation.
It has drawbacks. There are mistakes. We
won't discuss about that, but it's a
very good translation. The earlier the
first translation
he has done Urdu actually, originally
Urdu. From Urdu,
because it was so popular it got
translated into English, and this
particular
it's in six volumes
has been rendered to English by Muhammad
Akbar.
And edited by A. A. Kamal.
This translation per se, the English
language is not really really good.
It's quite poor.
Frankly. And I was happy when they came
out with the new translation by Zafar
Ishaq Ansari. Sorry. The revised edition
is by Zafar Ishaq Ansari.
Done by the Islamic Foundation, and that
translation in the English language is
much better. This translation had many
errors, grammatical errors also. So,
that translation is very good,
alhamdulillah.
By Zafar Ishaq Ansari, and many people
have translated. Amongst the good ones
available, English translation from the
Urdu
translation is by Zafar Ishaq Ansari.
He's done a good job. It's available
from the Islamic Foundation. I think
it's there in the list.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allahu Akbar.
Allahu Akbar.
Allahu
Akbar. Allahu [music]
Akbar.
Allahu Akbar.
Allahu
Akbar.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.